news daily from science mission cow
exists in two forms plans and says
system is known to cause neurotoxicity
authors in the journal Nature showed
that chronic traumatic encephalopathy
has increased expression of system as
well as various traumatic brain injury
conditions or TB is system spreads with
time and antibody against system could
rescue against ebay I in mouse models
this is us indicate that this tower
could be detected early in TBI and
rescued by system of antibody next in
normal healthy neuronal cells in the l1
phosphorylated by activated cdk5
recruits least one to dining leading to
sustain interaction of dining with
microtubule this causes increased
pausing during axonal transport d
phosphorylated ndl one causes the least
one and the Elven complex to release
from dining leading to increased axonal
transport authors in the journal Cell
reports show that in pathological state
like ALS p35 is cleaved into 325 which
causes prolonged and miss localized
activation of cdk5 this in turn causes
increased phosphorylation of ndl one
leading to strong recruitment of this
one to dining and subsequent destruction
of axonal transport for more news
visitors at ww science mission calm or
science mission facebook page